la feria tecnológica vivatec es un
gigante Laberinto en donde más de 2400
startups principalmente de Europa vienen
a presentar sus diferentes productos hay
de todos los gustos o para todos los
gustos que sea de Inteligencia
artificial que sea también para
inteligencia militar y otras cosas que
se pueden aplicar más para el día a día
como esta empresa de Estados Unidos
basada en Ohio que ha creado un
neumático que no se pincha Así que
parece que los neumáticos desinflados
pueden ser cosa del pasado
fabricamos llantas sin aire basadas en
una tecnología de la NASA es una
aleación de memoria de forma que se usó
en el programa del Rover que explora
Marte fabricamos llantas sin aire para
varios mercados motos bicicletas y
eventualmente para automóviles como no
tiene aire quiere decir que no se
pinchan y tampoco necesitan
mantenimiento pero con el mismo
desempeño y calidad del transporte de
una llanta normal la movilidad es uno
de los temas
presentados uno de los que más ha
llamado la atención es este que debe ser
comercializado a partir del próximo año
únicamente en Estados Unidos por
cuestiones de reglamentación
que es como una especie de de moto aérea
que tiene tres computadores y que no se
va a necesitar siquiera una licencia de
piloto para poder volar
es una máquina que tiene cuatro motores
térmicos y ocho motores eléctricos es
una máquina de propulsión híbrida
distribuida los motores térmicos
sustentan la máquina para permitirle de
colar y los motores eléctricos son los
que la estabilizan los que le permiten
realizar maniobras y aceleraciones y
desestabilizarla a Baja velocidad y nos
despedimos desde Climb y esta será una
de las cápsulas de lo futuro que nos va
a transportar no solamente en la ciudad
desde una tecnología completamente
eléctrica sino que también puede ir a
buscarnos a nuestras casas a la puerta
de nuestra casa o de nuestra oficina
esta empresa italiana como muchas otras
de las presentes aquí esperan Buscar la
financiación para poder continuar con
este proyecto el año pasado se
colectaron en total 13.500 millones de
euros